The first step to
having an awesome web application
is having an awesome game plan.
Let's define what our prototype should
do after completing each iteration.
Let's do some brainstorming to make
a checklist of deliverables that we
want to achieve with each
iteration of development,
by breaking down the project into
smaller, easier to manage mini-projects.
In the first pass at this project,
we'll create mock-ups for
every page in the restaurant menu app,
and design URLs for each page as well.
When I finish this iteration,
I can show my designs to my friends or
colleagues for feedback, and that's
enough work for our first iteration.
In the second iteration,
you'll set up all of the routings for
your application in Flask,
making sure you can navigate to
all of the URLs you want to create for
your application.
At the end of this iteration, you should
be able to navigate to all of your URLs,
even if the pages are not yet created.
After that, you will build on top of
what you made in the previous iteration
by creating all of your templates and
forms, and
making sure that they are properly
functioning within your application.
Once you have created and filled
out all of your HTML templates and
see them rendering in your application,
we can move on to the next iteration.
Now that you have a good grasp of
how your front-end code should look,
you will add the back-end functionality,
making sure all of the actions on
the web page are retrieving
data from your database.
When all of the code operations
work on all of your web pages,
you'll be finished with this iteration.
You will then add some endpoints
that allow the data to be sent if
the client requests a menu or
specific menu item in JSON form.
You will test these API calls
from within your browser to
know you have successfully
finished this step.
Finally, you will add some
styling with CSS, JavaScript, and
a few static images, to give your
application an appealing layout.
In this step, you will also incorporate
message flashing into your application.
I chose these steps to create our
application because I feel they
naturally build on top of each other,
and
have a clear deliverable at
the end of each iteration.
By keeping this in mind,
when you plan future projects,
you'll be better prepared for
all kinds of new challenges.